foreign  [Music]  bad luck we're grown adults we're fine  no actually you should go it's tradition  see she gets it I just want to ask is  that genetics or is it like Pilates  strands in your eyes they color them  wonderful we got your gift it's just  something borrowed brings you good luck  except for Uncle Greg who ended up  decapitated on that forklift but that's  not the knives fault someone just left  it in the bathroom  we belong together look at you I think  the left Booth is slightly lower than  the right boom  [Music]  I feel right  [Applause]  the Pirates  it's normal to feel scared if I'm not  gonna let anything happen to your family  I'm also feeling scared like the most  scared I've ever been in my whole life  it's like I just watched the ring you  know  here's the plan  screaming guys  [Music]  we're gonna fix it  nobody with my family  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  thank you for the cake knife  [Music]  foreign